yeah the one that is most well known as
Erasmus itself in terms of the mobility
for higher education students but then
also it's important to remember the
programs for adult learners for
vocational education and training
learners and for schools and for youth
and then at international level as well
so they've had a real impact across all
sectors of education I'm a courtesan day
at my captain core who's on haram Busan
native ashwatthama communicati Osaka
written by Frankfurt Odori at a time
read show colonnello blatant Korriban
ich Mikkel at an Omaha M min them fair
his hesitate vanishes thermostat - with
no sugar check it at Ostankino balushahi
moon come on we want to know how we can
make it work better
secondly in these straighten times we
need to get better value for money than
was previously the case and there are
always lessons that you can learn está
Claro que no podía a possibility near
graduating or us you know to be
experienced via an investor a film
revenant a in Opa really the canvas you
know to be experienced via
in on dr. Otto in Korea y no podía
bureaucracy no via do via Thomas Perez
via an Erasmus CK stole una cadena de
acontecimientos Colorado students or
we're putting seven programs into one
overall program we're including youth
and sports as part and parcel of the
package and that will be an integrated
program that more or less covers the
whole area and that's a big change from
what was there before
the Erasmus masters loan guaranty
facility was one of the most innovative
proposals in the program or one of the
most challenging to agree when we were
discussing it one of the things we did
was trying to deal with these concerns
and really have very strong guarantees
in the legal base on monitoring
evaluation protection for borrowers
anti-fraud measures to really protect
both the students who are the most
important things and then also the
European taxpayer they will be given
greater mobility they will have a better
set of skills hopefully it will address
issues which concern them which is
essentially getting the set of skills
that the marketplace wants so that they
can get a job and earn a living which is
a big crisis for young people across the
European Union of present time this is a
very human level the mission at Sian an
institution crouppen firm mention so
earthen introduced written studied
sue-shaun was in the on tashera eigen
limitation was Connie fondant under an
Ag until any of the volcanic ascension
EDM it's 11